- And then you're gonna feel a finger,
and some pressure.
- [Keith] Yup, yup, yup, yup, yup.
- [Dr. Rettig] OK, here we go.
- [Keith] Oh, oh.
- [Dr. Rettig] And there's your prostate.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Movember is this thing that helps raise
money and awareness for prostate cancer.
- Movember's a great organization,
we're not growing mustaches,
we're doin' one better.
- And it involves the finger.
- Butt stuff.
- Today we are gonna get our prostates
examined by a medical professional.
- I'm grateful for the
opportunity to raise awareness
for this thing and if we
can make some people smile
along the way, that's great.
- Prostate exam.
So, prostate cancer is the
most commonly diagnosed
cancer amongst men in the United States.
- Approximately 14% of
men will be diagnosed
with prostate cancer at some
point in their lifetime.
- Oh no!
- My grandfather died from colon cancer
and something that could
potentially affect me.
- It rarely occurs in men under 50.
- Oh.
- I don't actively think about
being susceptible to cancer.
It's not in my family, I'm a young person
who can take on the world.
- Testicular cancer is a
cancer that the Try Guys
need to worry about,
because testicular cancer
is the most common cancer
amongst men age 20 to 40.
- I only came in here for prostate,
I didn't know we were gonna
be doing nut feeling, too.
I didn't know I had to worry about this.
- Don't call it nut feeling.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] It's not nut feeling.
- Well, that's what it--
Is that what it is?
- Yeah.
(beeps)
- But, it's for a good cause.
- The mustache is a way to get
men to have a conversation.
We made it fun to talk about
a very serious set of issues.
- Why do you think men have such
a problem talking about health?
- I think it stems from masculinity
and this concept of man-up.
I remember when I was
growing up, you know,
you broke a finger, you just kind of
threw some duct tape on it.
It's a cultural thing, it's
getting past or redefining
what it means to be a man.
- If it takes just one finger
up the butt to find out
a life or death situation,
stick the whole hand up my butt.
- We're gonna trust this
doctor to take care of us,
take (laughing) real good care of us.
Should we do the testicular exam first
or go straight for the gold?
- We'll do both of them at the same time.
- [Voiceover] Oh, OK.
- [Keith] Same time?
- [Ned] What?
It's like a?
- Sequentially, with one--
(laughs)
(instrumental music)
- Oh my god, it's not what
I expected at all (laughs).
- So, we're gonna do
the genitourinary exam.
I'm gonna exam your testicles.
To see if there's any abnormality.
OK, we ready?
- [Ned] Hope there's not, yeah, I'm ready.
- OK, I think it's a good
idea starting at about age 20
to age 40 to do a self-exam every month.
- Ya hear that YouTube?
- Touch them nuts.
The testicular exam was nothin'.
- He just felt the top of the ball,
which I didn't realize
there was a top of the ball.
(coughs)
- And the left one feels just fine.
- Do I need to cough?
- [Voiceover] Just a
stranger touchin' your nuts.
- As does the right one, great.
- Nice, phew.
- So let's move on to
the digital rectal exam.
- Never had anything up my butt, well--
- Men that are age 25 to 40
have to get their nuts felt
and men that are age 50 or older
have to get their butts poked.
- That's basically right, yup.
- So 40 to 50, those are the golden years.
(laughs)
- Lie on your side with
your right side down.
Bring your knees up a bit
to expose your bottom, OK?
- Bottom exposed.
- Don't some people bend over?
- Yeah, that can be done also.
You can just stand up and lean over
and put your elbows on the table.
- Has anyone done, like, missionary style?
- The doctor had us lay on our sides,
Eugene, of course, bent
over because he's Eugene.
- I think it goes deeper
when you do doggie-style.
- And he poured a ton
of lube on that finger.
- It wasn't anything
sexual, he's a doctor.
- He pressed his finger up
against my delightful anus.
- Oh.
- [Dr. Rettig] Some pressure.
- And then just went--
(shooting noise)
- [Voiceover] He was in the butt.
- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
- And then he said, "OK, we're goin'."
And then, boom.
- And it's nice and smooth.
- Great.
- He just plunged his finger
deep inside my rectum.
It was hill deep.
- And, everything feels
fine, normal, smooth.
- So that was, efficient.
- [Voiceover] Super quick, very painless.
- [Eugene] Oh, oh.
Whoa, that was way deeper than I expected.
Lubed up, in and out.
- And you feel fine, all right.
- OK.
- And here's some tissue if you need it.
- What do you say after you're penetrated
by a handsome man?
- I just had a finger up my butt.
- Well, you did a great job.
(laughing)
- All in all, this was actually
a really educational day.
- Now I know what I'm getting myself into
and it's really, it's not that bad.
- It's super harmless,
it's super painless.
- Compare it to what women go through.
- Scraped in the vagina with metal stuff.
- Every year?
Oh.
- Cancer's not something you think about
but then when you go in
to get checked for cancer,
it's, it's really scary.
- That was a lot of talking
about cancer all at once,
does that ever get difficult?
- Of course it gets difficult
taking care of patients
who have serious illness, but
we do a good job sometimes
and these patients can
live quite some time,
and sometimes they're even
cured of their disease.
- Best thing for people to do,
in terms of getting involved,
is go to Movember.com,
sign up, get engaged,
understand what we're
trying to do in the world,
have a conversation with
your friends and family,
and get a team started
and raise a little money.
- I'm ready to go into the shower
and constantly feel my balls (laughs).
- But if you can, just grow the mustache.
- Grow a mo and save a bro.
- I wanna thank Dr. Rettig and
the UCLA Jonsson
Comprehensive Cancer Center.
- I'm grateful that we had the opportunity
to spread awareness by
spreadin' our cheeks.
Can we go one more?
- [Voiceover] Lube for YouTube.
- [Voiceover] There it is.
(yells)
- Nice job, guys.